Have you ever forgotten to stock your fridge with your favorite soda or beer?
I know I have.
You're really thirsty and all you're left with is that room temperature soda.
I'm gonna show you how to super chill a Coke in two minutes.
A room temperature soda is pretty nasty,...
...almost 80 degrees right out of the can.
But here's all you need to do to super chill it.
Depending on how many you wanna chill, get yourself a bowl with ice and water in it.
Then take ordinary salt, about a handful,...
...and put it in with the ice - water mixture.
Then, load up your drinks and stir them around.
This is the second law of thermodynamics.
Basically, the salt reduces the freezing point of the water...
...and allows it to become super chilled.
Okay, two minutes is up.
Let's take the thermometer from that room temperature Coke...
...and put it in the one we just super chilled.
Check it out! In two minutes, 43 degrees.
That's about the perfect temperature for a nice, cold Coke.
This will work with just about any drink, in a can or a bottle.
So, the next time you're dry, super chill your drink.